hey guys today is an awesome day well
actually in truth every day is an
awesome day right because every day is a
gift from God and we can boldly say that
this is the day that the Lord has made I
will rejoice and I will be glad in it
you see
you need to choose to live in that truth
and you know we as Christians we know
that life only starts to make sense when
we find God and then to abide in him he
in us and we in him and if you want to
share that with the world being bold not
ashamed then do that
and do it with the Merch this is a great
way of sharing the gospel it arrived
today found God and I'm gonna wear it
boldly I'm not gonna be ashamed because
we know that the gospel has the power to
save Souls so go and be bold and
proclaim the kingdom of God do it in
love in truth and through the spirit